okay for people who are joining the
livestream today we are in the late
stages of getting our database
integration system ready for version 12
language I happen to be on a different
computer today because I'm in New York
City for once um so here we go all right
what do we assume new entity class like
head should probably never fall out
their code what do you mean that I mean
it's slightly it's something that people
talking to not necessarily something
that is returned so but so this is
obviously wrong I mean this is kind of
silly do we have people here who
represent the enough of the entity world
to be able to talk about this
intelligently yeah okay so what what do
we think we might do for these I mean
this is clearly silly that's clearly not
going to work so what is what do we
think we're going to do for these
Sonne can you speak to that please I
don't have immediate suggestion the only
thing is that list that we are trying to
alight some information and in this case
no distinguishing information is left so
but I agreed that some more information
would be nice well why don't we do this
why don't we simply have somebody from
design here I mean why don't we just
have in this box perhaps what we can do
is to have an alighted version of this
code okay so for example in this case
population 3 that's fine we can do it
but if it got to be much bigger we
probably won't want to do it but we can
always have a dot dot dot there so at
least you have a fighting chance of
seeing what's there you know a deletion
that is similar to what happens was
short for example where we say you know
range of a thousand or something and
we'll see you know part of the beginning
part of the Act
am I making sense but stealin in German
police identity class is something that
he's still fully editable it's something
that you were you wanna you know maybe
you you set the limit wrong you didn't
want to say population goes to one you
want see population goes to between
should not format at all I think that
the input form is just fine is there a
code it's not like name like that I
don't think that's terrible i I agree
but then the question is what do we do
what circumstances do they format
maybe they shouldn't Tony can you speak
to this please
well I I agree Vista so Jason I think
named entities and named entity classes
should format because they have a nice
label in general while other things that
you construct should maybe not form it
okay what about food
I mean my claim is dead wait wait a
second wait a second I want Tony to
answer that question what about food
what about this case well sir this case
we had a natural language version so
that was fine
so I guess in the case where there is
natural language we can format like this
which is what we planned right Tony are
you there
but you could even get an entity class
like that
what I see it listen we got a decision
to make
okay you're proposing that in this case
where I don't know how the input form
for this case differs from this case
right but this case cannot start spewing
code all over the place am I making
sense
did you understand what I'm saying do I
have to repeat nothing but in my opinion
having the code floating having the
input floating around and for some time
it's not really a solution to the
problem no no no no no no no I'm gonna
explain what we need to do okay
this case is just fine we worked on this
extensively this case is just fine
obviously that case if I look at the
input form for that case I will see all
kinds of stuff that is similar to what
you're talking about now did you
understand what I'm saying
but similar to this right it's an
implicit entity description by making
sense
yes do you understand yes okay
so what I'm telling you is this can't
format like this right even if you want
this to format
without a special form this one should
not that make sense I think technically
there's not a big difference between the
two
it's money I don't care I don't care
yeah I don't care this case somehow we
managed to capture well I don't know
what happened in this case yeah well we
were we got this output this output is
really not right we really should have
some kind of mechanism is Michael here
by the way
um Michael here we go could we see if we
can find Michael please yes
okay so you know I think in a perfect
world we would keep with some kind of
comment the fat to be able to label this
output you see what I'm saying Tony yes
because this output without that is
pretty obscure I mean I don't know this
is somewhat reasonable with this with
this here
I guess
am i making sense to people I mean you
can't have this suddenly spliff out this
whole big mess here a little bit much so
we have a partial solution that might be
related for qualified properties if you
enter for instance Spain population 1990
there you can see an example of a
qualified property
you
did this ever go through design I think
they revealed that together a year or
two ago doesn't look quite right to me
it really doesn't look quite right that
plus doesn't look like it's in the right
place I took a screenshot I'm here it's
Billy from design I'll discuss it with
Brooklyn okay so the idea in that case
was that we have only the qualifier
values listed there could be many and if
we click the plus we also see what the
qualifiers are they are attached to not
nice
you
I mean
okay look killer choices in my view it
is not a choice to have I mean in the
case where this gets really complicated
with a composite entity type and so on
your right code is better okay
if the thing was but in this case where
it was generated from natural language
code is not better code is a big mess
making sense well I think I'm saying I
think that a more valuable distinction
is between the stuff that is the stuff
that is that is entered by people in the
stuff that is can be returned by things
I mean it's I think and I think it's
kind of an accident that you can do
things with control repo in generally in
general he will not have and where are
we going where are we going with this
we're not going to flip a switch that
will blow up all formatting right so
that's not that's not on the cards um
but you know so first of all for a
composite entity type I think we have no
choice but to show the code we agree for
weight depends because I think that when
you're doing at least if you look at the
documentation right now it just looks
positively or refined and it might I
mean that's not something that you won't
read it you probably need to look at
maybe you have recent enough version
otherwise one from CVS you have the link
down of all of the pages writes in
further down yeah I'm the agent it's
cool but also filter dancing class with
seminarians you can see that it blows up
or we should not have this by the way
this here we should not have this please
please remove that should I do it right
now I just don't want this list here
that list is in documentation only I'll
just remove it
look like some entities cannot be
simplified identity still extended
entity class a this could perfectly well
format as an orange blob say Mercury
Venus Earth and so on but I think maybe
they should just have a different icon
to signify that they're extended and and
that's my proposal of the icons in the
other notebook but this is not something
that you can edit and get something new
out of in the original entry class the
standard and this again to say this is
the case write a composite entity class
and if some on the live stream is
pointing out that it's important to
think about what happens when you copy
paste into or from script yes I agree
although I'm sort of hoping that a lot
of wolfing script will be written in WS
LS files that are edited in the notebook
editor so that you will still be able to
get all this nice formatting but what
you're saying is it's the case where
there's a where there's a composite
entity type but it's still a named
entity that looks nice and that could be
formatted with its name so does being in
display making yeah we're on I got it I
got it I got it I got it
we don't need to repeat that that's the
point right your the point that you're
making is if there is a clear name for
the entity this is a somewhat corner
case where there happens to be a clear
name for the entity that then you could
format using that name right right
no I don't think that the name is the is
the main distinction here because you
have database backed entities that can
be like the original ones and they are
not labeled they were format with the
canonical name which might be something
like horrifying new uit it will it will
not give you any information either name
could form or in a yellow blob because
they don't have labels tough luck there
is no parent oh you're things
interesting hat labels use the labels
right that's what you say otherwise use
the canonical name this is what
happening right now in in a yellow box
yeah
okay you're saying use the canonical
name even in the case of an external
database I'm saluting you okay so the
canonical name might be something kind
of horrifying sure in the case of an
external database but it's not gonna be
any less or refined an input form right
at least you're not repeating this whole
extended entity class which is the same
for all of them and it doesn't really
add much information but you need it in
the input form otherwise it helps
compute stuff sure what's your point my
point is that these guys should all be
yellow blobs and and then if you go to
the other notebook they should have do
you like on the distinguishing whether
they are extended filtered combined or
whatnot
okay fine but I'm not but I guess my
question is under what are the precise
rules for whether you get a yellow blob
or not I think if the head is entity you
always get a yellow blob that's my idea
okay even when the entity type is
something completely composite yeah and
and how much detail do you get in the in
the case where you get where it's where
you have a yellow box how much detail do
you get because clearly right now for
those early examples there with the
countries you're getting you know a
rather inadequate amount of detail okay
so my idea is that for single entities
single entities you will get label
that's either I mean if the type of
label is to label otherwise it's the
canonical name plus a little icon and
that's it and so if you're doing
something like aggregated entity class
over continent blah blah blah in the
yellow blob you get the name of the
continent yes that's that's the thing
you've aggregated on and so so it will
all have different chemical names you
will not have all the details of whether
if you have extended and then filtered
and then combined and whatnot you will
not see all that you will see only one
eye
which is the our most um
um the thing is Stephen that you are a
lot less likely to edit manually single
entities than you are to edit entity
classes and that's why I think Carlos
gets this where is so you're saying if
it's a single entity do one thing if
it's an entity clause do what then it's
if it's a complex one than you don't
form it we get to the case so okay hold
on so what you're proposing is whenever
it's a pure entity even if it's a
composite type or even if it's a
database driven you know named yellow
box it if it is a class only yellow box
it if it is a simple entity type and
simple entity class is that correct yeah
I would go I would go even further in
not format beam please identity cause
I'm sorry that's not on the table okay
then then yes I but we're not gonna do
that that's really stupid if I might say
so
come on format battle
we're not gonna format that we're gonna
have that big block don't be silly
that's how implicit I'm talking about
the ones ball the implicit ones I think
they are cool you're showing named
Claudia's that's what I said that's
that's what I said I just said the same
thing right I just said if it has if it
is not explicitly named if it has a yeah
I mean I
exactly what you were just okay so if
you both first and second argument are
string however that will fail however
look at this okay so this case that is a
pure entity why is that not an entity
class because that quacks like single
thing because we want to talk about when
you asked how many calories are in in a
certain thing you want you want a number
you don't want a long list of numbers
how many calories are in a burger so be
one candor to do a course caning like
operations okay okay so that that map's
nicely into this you know into this
hypothesis then that we can that we use
a yellow box when it is a single entity
but I mean this is a is that I mean you
various people have been trying to
attack the idea that we ever use a a
pure entity as opposed to an entity
class where things get composite this
this does not you're not going to try
and change your mind about this one no I
think that single entities should exist
not only that case is solid a single
entity but that case now that we have
aggregation in C class there would be a
better as is from algebra point of view
footing to write this thing so you could
consider this a food entity aggregated
on who type and ended food type as
properties but let's not go down that
road now
I don't understand that then then you'd
want to describe this as Nancy Claus
wouldn't you no no that's it okay so
let's put it this way if you take all
the food entities and then group by food
type and added food type you'll get
hamburger hotdog and so on and so forth
and so when you they could you could
consider every single one of these as an
entity in a class or one grade so they
still they still are single entities but
they come from a different class okay
all right okay let's keep going here all
right so I think then the proposal is if
it's a single entity we try to make it
yellow boxed in some way even in a case
like this so in this case in the output
here what will we do with that output be
open by default or what or do we just I
think for this version we may have to
punt on that issue I think we can't
guarantee to Canaille that but I think
in the future you're proposing this will
be a yellow box single entity but to
make it not so obscure we would open it
by default so your idea I would guess we
could even get rid of the plus minus and
have it just open all the time
[Music]
because like I don't see any system
setting so easily collapse
no no system settings are a waste of
time it's just my look I think this case
hold on this case is nice this case what
why is it's plural by the way that's one
food that's one entity that's been a
major source of confusion I think yeah
what why is that why is that Michael
Tony it looks like a bar yeah it seems
to do all that fun so maybe you can fix
that that would help I agree that that
has made me confused for sure
all right let's let's summarize what I
think we should do if there is a natural
language summary close it up and just
use the natural language summary
if there isn't a natural language
summary open it by default make sense
okay problems can we do that
I think there is a problem with making
the natural language thing sticky so
that when you copy paste stays no III
what when this is copy pasted I can't
believe that's a problem of the problem
click the checkmark
now copy they say ok if you evaluate it
goes away I think of course yes of
course that's what I just said well good
because I said well no no no no I
understand it can be cached but I I
don't think we necessarily want to do
that but I don't think we want to do
that because otherwise we will not have
a canonical form if we had you know
hamburger with you know french fries we
want that to canonicalize we want there
to evaluate to the same thing as
hamburger with fries make sense ok so
the thing I was saying I think is
exactly what we should do that is if
there is a natural language form use the
closed up version with the plus sign if
there isn't
use the opened form did you get what I'm
saying
okay that's what I think we should do
does anybody object to that no okay then
let's do it okay with respect to enter
the class can I repeat what I was saying
we should do or do people understand and
agree
anyone need to repeat it on time yes
I'll repeat it okay if it is a named
entity class like this okay oops that's
not what I wanted if it's a named entity
class then yellowbox it if it is in any
way composite
don't so in other words if we said
entity class country then show code if
we say entity class country you know
population
arrow you know take largest
three or something okay just show code
don't do this don't do what they did
here you get what I'm saying okay now
that means we're retiring effectively
this yellow box form
am I making sense yeah but we are you
but still if we are if we decide to not
yellow box also the core types like say
in the d-class country then it's not
clear to me whether it makes any sense
to yellow box for anything
well I'm sorry would you listen to what
I'm saying please what are you proposing
that we do not yellow box this no but
just that - not yellow box things like
Canada cross country no anti classic
country open clothes Lister is
excessively it is not yellow box it
because it's the generate version of the
one with rules I mean I think when it is
composite don't use the yellow box
because the yellow box is complicated
and you probably want the code and
saying only when it is not composite do
that does that make sense in it
that's a learnings and question is NZ
glass country open close list does that
format or not entity Clause country what
does this do I don't even know is that
it's all all countries no condition
basically so this is basically a core
type it's not but you can also view this
as a degenerate case of the filter
identity class
well this is very buggy whatever this is
doing it's not doing anything sensible I
didn't even know this work
I mean what happens if I just do a
single argument version it's invalid
nothing okay well why is that I I never
I've never seen the null list case
I think always works in place on
antilles okay I discussing this corner
case I mean are you asking should this
corner case have a special yellow box
formatting it's not quite clear is doing
because okay why not because you can
view it as also the energy class
corresponding to the core type that you
registered and so okay fine
so what so do we want to yellow box it
or not I think not I think there's an
argument to do it because you could make
the argument that all we could say I
mean we could certainly it would be an
easy argument to make that instead of
given explicit name there you could give
all that but as soon as you're giving
bla arrow blur and so on it's you know
it's using yellow box it's not using
yellow boxes
I mean I don't think we should get too
hung up on this because it's not
documented you can use a string in place
so why would you dress it with all that
anyway so I don't have a strong opinion
I was I just want to really I think it I
think it would be reasonable to make
that yellow box okay maybe maybe we
indeed shouldn't discuss that in all
these details I just wanted to draw
attention to this Pro know I might just
I'm just I'm just agreeing with you we
should use yellow box in this case I
don't see why not but this isn't right
but also from probably the icon is wrong
because the icon is showing yes there
should be a dope I figure I understand I
understand so it should indicate that
it's all of them okay so I think we're
we've got some understanding there so
let's let's take a look at what you're
talking about here so this is when you
have a single it's just okay okay yeah
that's that's another thing I have a
pretty hard stop here so and we don't
have a huge amount of time so okay
please don't continue okay so you have a
single entity coming out of entities
list and the first argument is not just
a pure type of string but it's something
that is generated by a computation I
think we should indicate this in some
way
what does okay wait wait wait wait wait
a second they in the yellow box the name
in the yellow box is based on what if
it's present the label property if it's
not present the canonical name and this
has already been the case for built-in
entities and in memory once it's
canonical name is the fallback for the
common name okay so it's a waiver so
this case here but I thought we were
discontinuing people ever using single
entities for this implicit case
I thought we would try to kill that I
would hope they die but what about food
so why we know because we don't worry
years of why we discussed even-steven
the reason why I cook that there is
because I think that if you look at the
icon if you look at the icon I drew for
aggregated they are kind of the same
thing this white head what are you
talking about do we want I thought we
did not want people to use implicit
single entities as opposed to entity
classes am I right or am I wrong see
indeed represent two different things
entity classes age I don't know answer
the question I'm asking okay we do want
people to continue using implicit
entities as opposed to entity classes
for some entity type like countries is
very unnatural to mix them and you them
course kind as one thing for food that's
very natural
and also they're not the same thing so
the implicit entity class of countries
with continent Europe will return a list
when you get out of an entity property
the increases entity will get a single
term aggregated value so they don't
behave to see if I if I do this and then
I say that then population I will get
the whole population of Europe yes no
yes I guess it's the average the hell is
that
I don't know using aggregated end okay
wait wait wait wait that's totally
stupid I thought that every property had
something that it did in in a composite
entity case and population surely should
not give the average because this is no
name Oh Michael wait wait wait
Tony can you explain what it's doing yes
I'm looking at I might take a moment
okay in general if you flew something as
a single entity that is a multi sync you
don't took it at the total you look at
some kind of average object no that's
only this is extensive versus intensive
quantities in the physical world toys
and I don't think population is ever I
never remember which way around these
are but population it's not like a
density thing it's like something
sensitive kennedys of chocolate chip
cookie you don't want 52,000 calories
because we have 890 cookies
extensive property
okay well so then you're saying is for a
particular entity property it is the
case that the aggregator the defaults
aggregator I mean I think population
would never want to be average it would
always want to be total heads by default
you know that's that's the beauty of
aggregated entity classes that you could
be the folks should work correctly but
did thanks nobody says Kanda this is the
total of all this is to cause current
version of them you have many city
countries in front of you and now you
look kinda every which version of it I
don't think that the okay listen the
question is if you are using an entity
as a nasty class okay describe are you
claiming that an entity is I'm still
getting the soul mate stop is there is
the kind of average yes okay in ever
until normally it's an average otherwise
you want to form an entity coop to view
it as one well you're saying that this
syntax entity of country is kind of a
silly thing suggesting that countries
are some kind of homogeneous material it
is City for that to be a but if you have
say farm this five thousand cows and you
asked for their for the image rate of
the cows of course you won't ever touch
them all also then getting a guy again
just number four the weight of the cow
in this form I mean III think there is
an argument wrong with me I would think
if you're trying to work out how much
the total you know somebody was trying
to figure out the you know how much the
farm is worth they probably want to add
up anyway I think that there are a
number of possible things you might want
to do you might want to know the number
of cows like so you want to count the
cows you want to know but you're saying
if you say the weight equipment you've
got the total weight of the cows or do
you get the average weight of the car or
what about the maximum weight or the
standard deviation all
those are a perfectly valid question yes
yes but that's not always it with the
question is the default and I think what
Michael is saying is the entity group if
you had the entity group of all cows and
you asked for the weight then you want
the total court if you have the entity
of all cows it's like the the average
you're saying with that that you you are
making the claim which I don't think
we've ever you know enunciated
specifically before that entity as
opposed to entity group as opposed to
entity class I think represents some
kind of average thing averaged over all
we discipline must be suspected food
that's the only viable optimal well I
understand that with respect to
countries the homogeneous hama homo
homogeneous asian of it is you know that
some it's much more no question right
how do you actually they're based on the
question live stream how do you ask for
the how do you change this to say give
me the total what do i do here
we navigate identity class you can do
that no no no no no without aggregated
entity class yes no i you think there's
no mechanism currently to overrate a
default i could gain function that's why
we now have this really i thought that i
thought that would be the attributes did
that in any old country data function
didn't the attributes do that or isn't
it part of the entity property mechanism
i think there is an undocumented fourth
arguments that allows you to do that but
not for any different class so you can
say entity class the same thing with
entity class and then you can say
counter population and piece of
qualifiers and then total but i don't
think if you work with a sequence well
yeah because you can apply aggregates
only two classes of entities and not a
single entity
well also i mean i think that all of
this
cash flow and confusion we're having is
because this single implicit entity is
really an abuse of notation and will
stop food you've got to have it no you
don't know if you have a breather that's
in class you don't anymore you can
express it with aggregated and plus but
give us this statement Khalu but in
general it is unavoidable like when you
already are save in species any species
is already the aggregated version of
many many millions of individual animals
yeah so what we provide an algebra of
types that you can use to construct
species from individual animals families
from species and so on and so forth and
if you are interested in the for
whatever reason you're doing data
science and you're you're interested in
the max the largest dinosaur you do one
thing if you're interested in the in the
average dinosaur you do another thing
and using a latency class puts this on
solid footing entity has a lot of
implicit assumptions that are difficult
to check and so on and so forth no
disagreement ok then zoom out for a
minute
can we can we make a table which we're
not going to be able to do right now of
all the different cases of entity entity
class entity group and what they do with
respect to these aggregators ok still
when can we do that please wait wait
wait waited with I want to make sure
we're doing that right Tony can you do
that please so there's functionality to
retrieve them it's not document it no I
do not ask you that I simply want to
know I simply want to get a table of
what it does right now what the system
does right now in those three cases but
they're basically two cases only just
one case that handles aggregation okay
watching and the other case that handles
grouping the one is more average like
and the others more total light
and if you have a single entity you are
having an average entity like Singh Lyle
if you have an entity group
you're totaling and so by the way all of
that is only true if the type of the
output is something like a number I mean
if the if the output is a string for
example or an image you know none of
that makes any sense yes so the default
aggregate function dissin identity I
mean okay okay thanks Michael
um okay we're not going to be able to
conclude this here because I also have
to go fairly soon um let me let's let's
loop back here for a minute okay you're
proposing these these cute icons will
teach you all entity what's that yeah
thank you for the cute it's the first
time I draw something right um okay but
in any case you're proposing them for
the case of not entity class where
you're proposing that we format as code
correct yeah but for single entities
with a conjugates first argument that
seems like a corner case to me but I
mean yes I agree that what we're doing
right now with single entities with
complicated first arguments doesn't make
a lot of sense
so Billy do you think you can make
something like those icons work yes I
believe so
okay and they're there to color icons
which is fine okay
I think the combined one should be three
colors it's like combining tell Billy
what you want I think we can make that
work
so there's another case which is the old
case that we probably want another icon
right the case if I'm not mistaken where
but no that was an entity class case
sorry that was a case never mind
that was this case here but what we
definitely don't want that filter down
representation there by making sense
that's very similar to this case where
we want I would say we just did just use
this icon right that red icon there in
this case yes
make sense
okay all right let's have a quick look
at the other things we're talking about
here
what is this okay so when you have a
database there's a lot of tables you
don't want to inspect them all at once
because it might take several minutes
might return a huge thing that you don't
particularly care about so current
behavior which is the default of SQL
alchemy which is framework using under
the hood is to basically grab the whole
connected component of the graph yeah
Ricardo's proposal is to take only the
single entity but message a warning
saying that we are dropping some links
to inspection and properties and so what
we had before was what you had before
but we're not going to do that it was a
big mess was not really a big mess it
was just that you couldn't find the name
that was they did what we want to do
here is like yeah okay before we get the
number of comments on the live stream
that are interesting here um Jeff is
commenting on asking for a saying that
pre-release four has a messy version of
database are you guys aware of this and
he's asking there's gonna be a
pre-release five um I don't know the
answer to either of those questions but
are you do you agree with the claim that
in pre-release for that the database
functionality was messy well we were in
the middle of renaming a lot of this
stuff so and looking big time okay so I
don't know whether there's a previous
fight coming I think that probably will
be um
okay that's coming if you have a
collection of food items you don't want
the average work total yes um
okay since we have a functional language
why not have a default aggregate
function that you can give to the entity
class yes I agree that would be a
reasonable thing to do that's what
that's what aggregated into classes for
yeah but but I think
as it is but imagine okay the question
is
is it convenient enough so for example
one could imagine another setup here
where's yes wait wait wait wait wait
where this says something like
aggregation function
arrow total okay what we gonna say okay
well I'm gonna say is this type just
below I create an entity class and then
say let's go blue why is it blue I know
what person you have Oh
because I misspelled it fine I created
never mind okay go ahead Hey
okay first I'll count three second
document is gonna be population was to
hold up okay
then more than this one here then just
come like that just just come to it
there darling just continent and then
yeah that's it
and then you transfer the population of
bad they're saying oh my god that's not
gonna give me a specific content I want
Europe the European continent okay if
you if you want one you do the ends list
or you you filter I know I I rather like
this type of thing I don't know why
we're not doing this type of thing as an
alternative the issue is that for
different properties you might want
different defaults and then you get into
a mess how do you specify that oh and
the other the other thing that you you
can do if you want just Europe is you
take that thing and you wrap it in
entity and you put that second element
Europe that won't work
it does work no okay
let's look at these other things I
really unfortunately have to go um okay
so the issue here is what whether to get
the whole connective component or
whether just to get the individual okay
and and also I think it's whether I
think we all agree on getting a single
table at least as default the question
is when for verse why does but why does
SQL lat alchemy thing not do that why do
they think it's worth getting the whole
connected component
I will never appreciate answer the
problem is that you are getting with a
database that is not complete
the moment you start dropping relation
so the way it works with ask alkene is
that they provide one function that can
either inspect the whole thing or a
connected component starting from some
things and then then they have finer
grained methods for getting this
information so you can actually do both
there just provide different methods now
what I think is that the problem we will
have a problem when we write to this so
if you inspect one database and then you
want to reproduce it locally so if you
have inspected the database partially
you end up with something that is
perfectly fine for reading but it's not
gonna be good for writing and so the way
the message should be should on the
right track not on Rita
by the way Karla you didn't lose my
proposal here which is a third one which
was to do lazy inspection
we're gonna do it for this version learn
it for sure yeah not for this version
services
okay so we're if we restrict on it for
this immediate version then yes but just
to list it in principle I think it would
make sense to to just mention it
if I may suggest can we can we move this
discussion about these dangling
references for the next time poor Carla
do you think or do you want the answer
I have no unless you think there's an
easy answer I mean to me look they're
gonna end up having to be an option to
decide I mean this is basically it's
kind of like the save that include
definitions options to various functions
that say do you want to you know sort of
a kind of indirect through all the
dependencies or not
laughs yeah I have something useful to
include definitions and sometimes it
isn't
yep okay live stream hold on the
question here enter the value of entity
group does it always provide the total
how do you get if you say enter the
value of entity group can you get for
example the media or the distribution of
a property so for the case of entity
group there's also a default aggregate
function for each property and there's
some undocumented syntax which you can
retrieve that function for each property
so given how it is painted if you can
change it there's no syntax for it
to have entity values so okay we need a
separate discussion that aggregation
object and whether whether I mean I
understand that there's a mechanism here
with aggregated entity class for doing
this the question is whether we also
want to provide some simplified syntax
for these other cases
okay I have to go guys um to be
continued
and unfortunately gonna need to follow
up on this um alright see you guys soon